ein riesiger frachter verschwindet in
einem tosenden treffen es war ein rätsel
wie ein fast 300 meter langes schiff
einfach verschwinden konnte die behörden
geben dem kapitän und seiner besatzung
die schuld aber daran gibt es zweifel
deco hätte ihr leben nicht riskiert
werden es beweisen
die beweise liegen auf dem meeresgrund
sie bereit und es gibt überraschen
das schiff ist erst inkludiert und dann
explodiert
fest steht dass 44 menschen an bord
lebten als sie in den taifun fuhren
niemand überlebte was ist passiert
[Musik]
achter september 1980 bmw dhabi fährt
durch den westlichen pazifik kurs auf
japan
kapitän jeffrey an der hhl hat das
kommando über das riesige schiff
der zweifache vater ist für die dächer
und die insgesamt 44 menschen an bord
verantwortlich
[Musik]
sind die wetterberichte schon da ja ich
hab sie hier
jeffrey an der hell oder gewinn wie ihn
alle nannten war ein sehr kompetenter
seemann dass seine persönlichkeit anging
so setzte er immer auf kontrolle durch
konsens
nigel melker erster offizier an bord
dhabi schiff und besatzung sind ihm sehr
vertraut
david es war wundervoll auf der
derwische unterwegs zu sein sie war fast
nagelneue alles funktionierte tiptop
wenn man noch nie auf so einem frachter
war kann man sich kaum vorstellen wie
ein baum groß sie waren
mit 294 metern ist die derwische länger
als die titanic und auch deutlich
schwerer ihre neuen frachträume fassen
insgesamt rund 160.000 tonnen das
brücken denkt ist zehn stockwerke hoch
ein derart riesiges schiff kann drei
kilometer brauchen um anzuhalten und
mehr als ein kilometer um zu wenden die
davis ist ein schüttgut frachter und
kann alles von getreide bis hin zu öl
transportieren auf dieser fahrt hat sie
157.000 tonnen eisenerz geladen nach dem
ablegen in kanada hat sie die südspitze
afrikas umrundet und ist jetzt nur noch
wenige tage von ihrem zielhafen entfernt
kawasaki in japan aufgrund ihrer größe
hat sie den langen weg nehmen müssen
sie war ein sogenannter capesize
frachter denn mit 44 metern breite und
gut 18 metern tiefgang passte sie nicht
durch den panama und den suezkanal also
musste sie am kap horn und dem kap der
guten hoffnung entlang durch einige der
rauesten mehrere der welt
schiff und besatzung sind inzwischen
fast zwei monate auf see unter den mehr
als 40 seeleuten an bord ist auch der 19
jährige deck arbeiter peter lambert es
ist sein zweites jahr auf see und er
liebt seine arbeit
er sprach von nichts anderem er hat es
geliebt ich glaube die fahrer werden
geboren wie kann man nicht machen
die man ist den anderen
besatzungsmitgliedern sehr eng verbunden
manchmal hängt das eigene leben davon ab
eine schiffsbesatzung ist wie eine
familie
denn man ist über lange zeit gemeinsam
an bord
was denn jetzt einfach dahin ehefrauen
dürfen ihre männer auf sie begleiten
eine ungewöhnliche aber beliebte
unternehmensphilosophie
die 24 jährige emilie hutchinson ist
eine von zwei ehefrauen an bord
bisher verlief die fahrt ruhig
ketten was spannendes
etwas zu spannend der erste offizier
curry bayliss überreicht seinen kapitän
wetterberichte über ein schnell
herannahen des unwetter taifun orchid
der westliche nordpazifik wird auch als
taifun korridor bezeichnet die taifune
die sich dort bilden können einen
durchmesser von über fünf oder sechs 100
kilometern haben mit winden von über 160
kilometern pro stunde die extremen
segeln verursachen äußerst zerstörerisch
um es nicht in gefahr zu bringen muss an
der er sein schiff mindestens 320
kilometer weit vom unwetter entfernt
halten aber es gibt ein problem er bekam
drei wetterberichte aus gramm aus tokio
und aus hongkong und jeder verortete
taifun orchid woanders
großartig drei unterschiedliche
vorhersagen
damit muss kapitän an der l versuchen
dem unwetter auf gut glück auszuweichen
du musst doch deine erfahrung und sein
wissen setzen um deine position im
verhältnis zum unwetter festzustellen
sowohl der taifun als auch das schiff
sind in bewegung das unwetter zu umgehen
ist eine enorme herausforderung
als vernünftiger seefahrer wird er sie
die drei taifune behandelt haben er hat
sicher nicht geraten welche vorhersage
die richtige ist er änderte den kurs
nach norden und osten ab um allen dreien
auszuweichen wenn wir diese
geschwindigkeit beibehalten sollten
durch rutschen können
man plant wenn ich kurs und
geschwindigkeit für die nächsten 24
stunden beibehalte lasse ich ihn wohl
hinter mir vielleicht kriegen wir ein
bisschen was ab aber nicht die volle
breitseite
hier spricht der kapitän das wetter wird
schlechter also sorgen sie bitte dafür
dass das schiff
gesichert sind
es war unternehmens richtlinie dass bei
aufkommendem schlechtem wetter lüftungs
zugänge abgedeckt wurden und man alles
so absicherte dass das schiff gerüstet
schwere see gehört dazu das heißt aber
nicht dass man eine wetterwarnung auf
die leichte schulter nimmt
einer der wichtigsten aufgaben ist das
abdichten der großen und kleinen booten
peter lambert ist noch in der
einarbeitungsphase
jeder mochte ihn was auch immer getan
werden musste er packte mit an
wir machen nur noch acht knoten nach
einigen stunden wird klar dass der plan
des kapitäns nicht aufgehen wird trotz
der kursänderung kommen sie in
schlechtes wetter die wogen den fluten
erschweren es bereits das tempo
beizubehalten
vielleicht kommen wir so besser voran
die bedingungen verschlechtern sich
weiter das unwetter hat plötzlich die
richtung geändert und zieht jetzt direkt
über sie hinweg
in der nacht erreicht der wind
geschwindigkeiten von bis zu 80
kilometern pro stunde und irgend über
sieben meter hohe wellen auf
wir werden es wohl aussitzen müssen bei
drehen bitte
bei drehen
wind am bündnis zu stark
der kapitän pasta ausrichtung und kurs
so an dass die wellen an die
steuerbordseite schlugen so steigt und
fällt das schiff dann in der länge kommt
aber nicht den roller oder stampfen
jetzt war der mittelpunkt des treffens
näherkommt erreichen die winde 100
kilometer pro stunde und sorgen für mehr
als zehn meter hohe wellen
solche bedingungen erleben nur wenige
menschen auf see
der wind ist sehr laut er brüllt
förmlich das schiff stampft man sieht
kaum etwas die ganze situation ist
einfach und
allen an bord bleibt nichts weiter übrig
als die schwere see über sich ergehen zu
lassen
[Musik]
das beeinträchtigt die besatzungs
tagelang müdigkeit macht sich breit weil
niemand schläft vor allem wenn man von
schwerem wellengang durchgeschüttelt
wird
captain andere blieb wahrscheinlich auf
der brücke als das unwetter herrschte er
musste ja da sein und sehen was los ist
man ist einfach die ganze zeit wachsam
müde aber wachsam
als die zweite unwetter nacht anbricht
funkt die doppische ihre position ans
festland und nimmt kontakt mit einem
schiff in der nähe auf hier wie da
vischer wie gefällt ihnen das wetter
großartig
war auf einem containerschiff das
denselben hafen in japan ansteuerte
wir sprachen über ukw mit der derwische
und hatten ausgemacht die jungs an bord
in tokio zu treffen in einem nachtclub
namens fuß in roppongi da halten wir
zusammen hingehen aber dazu kam es
leider nicht mehr
[Musik]
20 grad steuerbord 20 grad steuerbord
ketten
inzwischen haben über zwei tage lang
andauernde orkanartige winde die wellen
auf monströse höhlen gepeitscht
dann
die wird heftig
[Musik]
das kreischen sich bietenden stahls kann
nur eines bedeuten
wir werden sinken
hallermann von bord
[Musik]
albert
sie werden erst in letzter sekunde
begriffen haben was geschieht
[Musik]
fünf tage später hat sich treffen orchid
endlich aufgelöst aber niemand hat etwas
von der david gehört nicht einmal eine
notebooks
tagesanbruch sahen wir helikopter der
japanischen küstenwache über uns sie
flogen alle aufs meer raus
sie suchten nach der derwische
die rettungstrupps hoffen noch eine spur
des schiffs mit 44 menschen an bord zu
finden
elf tage nach dem letzten funkspruch von
der mwb fischer hat eine ausgiebige
suche der japanischen küstenwache keine
anzeichen für überlebende ergeben 45
kilometer von ihrer letzten bekannten
position entfernt wird ein ölteppich
entdeckt aber das größte je auf see
verlorene britische schiff bleibt
verschwunden
es war ein rätsel wie ein fast 300 meter
langes schiff einfach verschwinden
konnte
alle 44 besatzungsmitglieder und
passagiere sind höchstwahrscheinlich tot
unter ihnen auch der 19-jährige deck
arbeitet peter lambert seine familie ist
verzweifelt meine mutter war völlig am
boden sie fragte immer nur warum
warum warum
ist das schiff gesunken wie ist er
gestorben warum
das unglück wird von orchid
zugeschrieben und als höhere gewalt
eingeordnet
aber daran gibt es zweifel
warum verschwindet ein gutes stabiles
schiff plötzlich ohne einen notruf
[Musik]
ich sagte mutter ich werde herausfinden
wie das schiff sinken konnte und warum
peter dort ums leben das verspreche ich
dir
der damals 28 jährige paul lambert macht
ernst und wendet sich an die
seefahrergewerkschaft im vereinigten
königreich
ich wollte mich nach der dabeler
erkundigen das sollten sie sich ansehen
mehrere verfahren gesunken und niemand
unternahm was genau wie bei der davis
derselbe frachter typ rembert erfährt
dass eine erschreckende anzahl von
massengutfrachtern gesunken ist im
durchschnitt kamen alle sechs bis sieben
wochen bei einem schiffsunglück alle an
bord ums leben
die ära der schwimmende särge sonaten
für lambert ist klar die leben von
seeleuten sind in gefahr aber niemand
unternimmt etwas bis sechs jahre nach
dem unglück ein weiterer zwischenfall
alles verändert
der wendepunkt kam 1986
als das schwesterschiff der derwische
die keulen bridge vor der küste irlands
in schwierigkeiten gerät
es traten große risse am schott 65
direkt vor dem dix haus auf
[Musik]
die typische ist eines von sechs
schwesterschiffen die von stahlträgern
entlang des rumpfs verstärkt werden
aber in der bauphase werden die träger
an schott nummer 65 verschweißt so dass
eine potenzielle schwachstelle entsteht
drei dieser sechs schiffe sind auf see
in massive schwierigkeiten piraten
die hinterbliebenen des ta bischer
untergangs und viele andere die sich
damit befassen folgern aus diesem
offensichtlichen konstruktionsfehler
dass die da besser wo wegen eines
mangels an shop 65 gesunden ist das sah
sehr eindeutig aus
und wenn es tatsächlich ein
konstruktionsfehler war der zu dem
unglück führte könnten noch mehr leben
in gefahr sein
wir schicken wir sie kennen alle von
bord
es geht nicht nur um peter da muss etwas
getan werden
hallo paula wird noch mal hatten sie
schon gelegenheit das material zu
sichten wegen des verdachts zu schott 65
will lambertz die behörden dazu bringen
ihr urteil noch einmal zu prüfen
aber nach zwei jahren der ermittlungen
und neun jahre nach dem unglück kommen
sie erneut zu dem schluss dass tayfun
arquette für das verschwinden der fische
verantwortlich ist von höherer gewalt
war die rede
ein ergebnis das die familien nicht
hinnehmen wollen die dabeler st zweimal
erst im südchinesischen meer und dann in
einem meer aus vertuschung sehen sie
sich das an aus ländersicht wird es nur
dann eine ordentliche untersuchung geben
wenn die hinterbliebenen der opfer die
dinge selbst in die hand nehmen wir
müssen die wahrheit selbst herausfinden
zunächst müssen sie das wrack aufspüren
sie müssten feststellen wo in etwa das
schiff lag und zwar anhand des
ölteppichs den die japanische
küstenwache entdeckt hatte
im suchgebiet liegt der meeresgrund bis
zu fünf kilometer tief
[Musik]
damals war es kaum möglich große
bereiche des meeresbodens abzusuchen das
wrack galt als praktisch unauffindbar
und
die anderen hinterbliebenen lassen sich
davon nicht abschrecken gemeinsam
organisieren sie die finanzierung einer
achttägigen suche und sie haben glück
14 lange jahre nach dem unglück finden
die suchtrupps endlich das wrack
wir haben die
das kann man erst mal gar nicht fassen
wir wissen wo sie ist wo 44 menschen
begraben
jetzt fordert lambert die britische
regierung auf die untersuchung
fortzusetzen
diese massengutfrachter müssen unter die
lupe genommen werden diejenigen die
nicht seetüchtig sind müssen außer
dienst gestellt und abgefragt werden die
leute müssen sich auf ihr schiff
verlassen können und nicht in sorge
leben ob sie je wieder nach hause
zurückkehren
angesichts des öffentlichen drucks
bewilligt die britische regierung die
mittel für eine umfassende expedition
und dieses mal werden schwere geschütze
aufgefahren
[Musik]
sie holten wissenschaftler von o2 mit
dazu damals das fortschrittlichste
forschungszentrum für ozean und tiefsee
und vielleicht sogar noch heute
die woods hole oceanographic institution
deren team die titanic entdeckt hat wird
nun die da vischer untersuchen in über
4000 metern meerestiefe
die untersuchung der davis war die
weltweit erste hoch anspruchsvolle
forensische analyse
der damals 38-jährige robotertechnik
groupon steuert das modernste
unterwasserfahrzeug der welt
unsere aufgabe war es dort unten nach
hinweisen auf mögliche szenarien zu
suchen war um das schiff gesunken war
war vielleicht der propeller abgefallen
hatte das ruder versagt gab es ein feuer
im maschinenraum
insgesamt werden 13 denkbare ursachen
für den untergang der da bisher
festgestellt darunter ein möglicherweise
katastrophales versagen an schott 65
ist hängt schon wieder andrew brown will
mit seinem unterwasserfahrzeug möglichst
umfassende aufnahmen vom wrack einfanden
und weg
die ermittler achten auf jedes detail
es war eine enorme herausforderung
unsere kameras baumelten praktisch in
über vier kilometer tiefe an einem faden
über einem trümmerfeld das an einen
eingestürzten wolkenkratzer erinnerte
ganz schön kalt für die computer
der doktorand alex gleiches analysiert
gemeinsam mit professor detlef volk die
aufnahmen des wracks
[Musik]
die sichtweite lag bei höchstens zehn
meter mehr konnte man nicht sehen
die trümmerteile liegen über mehr als
ein kilometer weit auf dem grund
verteilt
gehen wir mal heran
[Musik]
den namen des chefs da unten in 4200
metern tiefe zu sehen
diesen moment werde ich niemals
vergessen
[Musik]
warum sank die doppische
17 jahre nach dem tragischen
schiffsunglück mit 44 toten kommt
offenbar licht ins dunkel
[Musik]
vier kilometer unterhalb der
meeresoberfläche
suchen ermittler mit hilfe einer
ferngesteuerten kamera nach hinweisen
darauf warum der schüttgut frachter mw
da wischer im pazifik gesunken ist
völlig zerfetzt seht euch das an
das riesige schiff liegt in über 2000
trümmerteilen am meeresgrund
ich fragte mich warum es so zertrümmert
war warum ist mich denn zwei oder drei
teile zerbrochen war wie zb die titanic
groupon hat viele schiffswracks
untersucht aber so etwas ist ihm noch
nicht untergekommen
es hat wohl alle verblüfft wie weit die
trümmer verteilt lagen
bug und heck des schiffes lagen ziemlich
weit auseinander
und alles dazwischen der gesamte
schiffskörper war größtenteils zu
konfetti geworden
[Musik]
die verbogenen metall fragmente lassen
auf eine massive gewalteinwirkung
schließen
aufgrund ihrer einzigartigen doppel
hüllen konstruktion ist die da vischer
bei ihrem untergang erst implodiert und
dann explodiert
als die deutsche bank drückten die
fluten ihre wasserdichte doppelrolle
nach innen dadurch wurde die
eingeschlossene luft so zusammengedrückt
dass die höhle zerplatzte
sie trat in einer schockwelle aus und
dabei wurde wohl ungefähr die energie
mehrere tonnen tnt freigesetzt
am meeresgrund waren also nur noch chefs
trümmer zu finden die von dieser enormen
kraft verformt worden waren
anders ausgedrückt die explosionen waren
die folge des untergangs nicht seine
ursache die ermittler wissen noch immer
nicht wie es zu dem unglück kam
das unterwasserfahrzeug macht tausende
hochauflösende aufnahmen
der mittlere durchforsten sie nach
anzeichen von schäden die vor dem
untergang des schiffes auftraten vor
allem in der nähe der bekannten
schwachstelle anstatt 65
[Musik]
wir mussten herausfinden ob die
verformten metallteile bei schaut 65 auf
einen spruch oder einem verformung bruch
zurückging ein verformung bruch ereignet
sich langsam ein sportbuch schlagartig
aber die ermittlungen führen in einer
sackgasse schott 65 zeit ganz klare
spuren des platzens beim sinken es war
nichts 65
das ist passiert als sie schon seit
der untergang der da bist also nicht wie
vermutet auf einen konstruktionsmangel
zurückzuführen
wir stellten fest dass all die leeren
laderäume hinter schaut 65 implodiert
explodiert waren als das schiff sank
es gab also keine risse anschaut 65
dann muss etwas anderes zu dem unglück
geführt haben
wir werden sinken
argument von bord
alle verborgen
wenn es kein konstruktionsfehler wahr
ist dann vielleicht die fracht der da
bitter für ihren untergang
verantwortlich
dieser hatte eisenerz geladen das ist
dieses schnee ähnliche feine material
das überall verteilt war
ernst frachter sind gefährliche schiffe
denn sie haben eine so schwere dichte
fracht dass sie sofort sinken wenn sie
geflutet werden und den auftrieb
verlieren ein ernsthafter singt wie ein
stein
auf dieser fahrt hat die dynamische
157.000 tonnen eisenerz geladen
es ist so schwer dass nur sieben ihrer
neuen frachträume zum teil gefüllt
werden konnten
man muss sicherstellen dass massen
schwerpunkt und mieter zentrum
korrigieren die sogenannte meta
zentrische höhe sonst hat man ein totes
schiff im feld der auftrieb und es
schwankt um
die crew das schiff möglicherweise
falsch beladen
können wir los ein totes schiff ist
besorgniserregend
danke die ermittler prüfen noch einmal
die unterlagen vom ausgangshafen der
davis aber nichts deutet auf ein problem
hin dass das unglück erklären könnte sie
wenden sich wieder ihren gesicherten
informationen zu in der nacht des
untergangs herrscht extrem schwere see
ein schiff das in denselben taifun
geriet berichtete von 10 bis 30 meter
hohen wellen
wie gefällt ihnen das wetter
man steht auf der brücke und sieht vor
sich nur eine wand aus wasser fährt man
über die welle oder hindurch
professor faulkner hat eine theorie die
damals noch umstritten ist
möglicherweise wo die die derwische von
einer monsterwelle erwischt
so etwas dürfte es seit anbeginn der
zeit geben
seit jahrhunderten berichten seefahrer
von riesigen wellen die aus dem nichts
zu kommen scheinen
monsterwellen werden oft als einzelne
welle beschrieben die viel höher ist als
alle anderen meist doppelt bis dreimal
so hoch sie kommt aus einer anderen
richtung als die meisten anderen ist
instabil und bricht und wenn sie auf ein
schiff trifft kann sie unglaubliche
wucht haben
und weiß wie sie entstehen sie kommen
aus dem nichts und manchmal treffen sie
auf schiff
hat eine monsterwelle das schicksal der
derwische samt 44 menschen an bord
besiegelt
es wäre furchtbar sie kommen zu sehen
und genau so furchtbar sie nicht zu
sehen
[Musik]
ermittler untersuchen den untergang des
frachters davis im september 1980 wurde
sie womöglich von einer monsterwelle
getroffen
das team sucht auf den aufnahmen des fox
nach hinweisen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir sprechen hier von
135.000 standbildern wir mussten sie wie
teile eines puzzles zusammenfügen
jedes bild wurde einzeln genauestens an
das jeweils daran anschließende angefügt
so dass ein großes gesamtbild entstand
dass man auf keinem anderen wege hätte
anfertigen können
sie erschufen ein riesiges mosaik von
chefs war
ein großteil des schiffs wurde
zertrümmert der bug aber nicht
bemerkenswert
[Musik]
der bub war größtenteils intakt
das deutete darauf hin dass er geflutet
war und darum nicht zerbrach oder unter
wasser platzte
dies lässt rückschlüsse auf den grund
des untergangs zu
[Musik]
hat womöglich der geflutete buch das
schiff sinken lassen
wir fragten uns wie konnte das wasser
eindringen und warum
bei ihren nachforschungen stoßen die
ermittler auf eine beunruhigende
aufnahme
wir hatten hochauflösenden aufnahmen von
burg
darauf war zu sehen dass ein deckel zur
ladeluke fehlte
die flügel schrauben waren unbeschädigt
sie waren also nicht angezogen worden
es wurde klar dass der deckel nicht
verschlossen gewesen war
der offene open deckel führt zu einem
lagerraum unterhalb des verdecks
sehen wir zu dass das schiff gesichert
ist
wurden die flügel mutter nahm lobten
deckel möglicherweise nicht fest genug
angezogen
alles schön fest 10
falls er während des unwetters aufging
könnte tonnenweise meerwasser in den
lagerraum darunter eingedrungen sein und
den bug des schiffs beschwert
der bug senkt sich ab während er voll
wasser läuft und irgendwann liegt ihr
nicht mehr so hoch wie ihr sollte
dann werden die wellen immer weiter und
weiter aufs deck schlagen und
tonnenweise meerwasser auf die großen
haupt ladeluke stühlen
diese lupen deckel sind stabil aber auf
diese das sind sie nicht ausgelegt
mitten im unwetter können sich die
wellen gut zwölf meter hoch auftürmen
und wenn sie auf die lupen deckel
einstürzen entspricht das hunderten
tonnen von last
eine zwölf meter hohe welle kann mit
einer wucht von 400 tonnen auf das
schiff einstürzen dafür sind die lupen
deckel nicht ausgelegt es ist nur eine
frage der zeit bis sie nachgeben
[Musik]
seht mal sobald der erste lupen deckel
nachgibt läuft der fast leere laderaum
schnell voll und zieht den bug noch
tiefer in die heranrollenden wellen
luken deckel nummer eins gibt nach
laderaum nummer zwei ist leer fühlt sich
mit wasser und zieht das schiff noch
weiter nach unten bis auch laderaum
nummer drei vor läuft ist das schiff
schon unterwegs zum meeresgrund
ermittle sie in belege für ihre theorie
dass der untergang unter totaler an bord
hätte verhindert werden können wenn die
crew den vorderen kleinen luken deckel
ordentlich gesichert hätte
das wird in familien nicht gefallen
die hinterbliebenen werden vor der
presse über die neuen erkenntnisse
informiert
als wir es den familien sagten wirkten
sie erstaunt es
tut mir leid es sieht so aus als sei der
lupen deckel nicht gesichert worden
[Musik]
und was bedeutet das
es war wohl menschliches versagen
menschliches versagen der vordere locken
decke war nicht gesichert
nein sie müssen sich irgend dass das auf
menschliches versagen hinauslief brachte
sie wohl wirklich in rage sie sagt nein
das waren profis es ist undenkbar dass
so eine kuh etwas tun würde dass sie in
gefahr bringt
sie liegen falsch und das werde ich
beweisen
die crew hätte ihr leben nicht riskiert
all die jahre konnten wir nicht
anständig trauern gehen sie bitte
feiden wir haben gekämpft informiert
und alles getan was nötig war und dann
sagen die einen es war menschliches
versagen
sie sich die bilder es war nicht die
lupe wir werden es beweisen der
ehemalige erste offizier nigel mertes
glaubt nicht dass ein fehler der crew
zum untergang der bücher führte er
sollte bei ihrer letzten fahrt an bord
seien aber ein crew wechsel in letzter
minute rettete sein leben
manche sagen ich sei eine riesige
glückspilz stark auf der david hätte
sein sollen als sie sagen
[Musik]
mit den meisten an bord war ich zuvor
schon auf sie gewesen ich kannte sie
alle sehr gut
märz ist überzeugt dass die ermittler
falsch liegen er bezweifelt dass die kuh
jemals die vordere luke ungesichert
gelassen hätte
jeder der das schiff kannte wusste dass
das nicht sein konnte das war mir klar
als ich das foto von der vorderen luke
sei an der noch teile der wolf leine
hingen sie war gut gesichert worden
[Musik]
als erster offizier auf der davis
stellte merkt es sicher dass die crew
den vorderen lupen deckel mit einer
sogenannten patch cradle festzurrt
wir sicherten die ladeluke deckel damit
so konnten sich die flügel mutter nicht
aufdrehen ich hatte keinen zweifel daran
dass die crew dieses prozedere
durchführte
diese seien reste und die aussage von
nigel melker ist stellen die
erkenntnisse der ermittler infrage
etwas anderes muss die fatale flutung
des buchs verursacht haben
bei der suche nach der wahrheit soll
marin helfen das maritime
forschungsinstitut der niederlande hier
kann das verhalten unterschiedlichster
schiffe bei fast allen wetterbedingungen
simuliert werden
nur hier ließ sich der wellengang
nachstellen der während des unglücks
herrschte wir konnten jede art von
wellen erzeugen
solche mit langem kampf mit kurzem kann
wählen die aus unterschiedlichen
richtungen kommen
damals war das ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal
das maritim soll die bedingungen während
es zwei von orchid nachstellen und ihre
auswirkung auf die da vischer
untersuchen hat etwas anderes als
menschliches versagen zur katastrophe
geführt die familien hatten hohe
erwartungen wir standen unter großem
druck ergebnisse zu liefern
wir wollen die wahrheit wird
zweifelsfrei nachgewiesen dass jemand
einen fehler gemacht hat akzeptieren wir
das
für den davis versuch wird der wellen
tank anhand detaillierter
meteorologischer informationen über teil
von orchid programmiert sensoren am
viereinhalb meter langen exakten nachbau
des schiffs sollen die belastung
erfassen die während des taifuns auf das
schiff und seine vorderen lupen deckel
einwirkte
es ist ein absolut maßstabsgetreuen
nachbau wir haben auch den antrieb
nachgebaut denn die geschwindigkeit des
schiffs ist wichtig die fracht verhält
sich anders je nachdem ob es mit 0 oder
zwei oder vier knoten unterwegs ist
ziel ist es einen unvoreingenommenen
eindruck davon zu bekommen wie sich das
schiff im unwetter verhält
in unserem tag sind alle nötigen
gegebenheiten vorhanden die für das
verhalten und die sicherheit eines
normalen ships relevant sind
stundenlang fährt das modell durch den
blüten dem taifun
selbst als große wellen über den bug
spülen stellen die sensoren keine
anzeichen eines versagens der vorderen
lupen deckel fest
während des versuchs gab es dramatische
vorfälle wie wellen die über das fordert
kamen und auf den lippen deckel
einstürzten aber nur dadurch hätte das
schiff nicht senken können da musste
noch mehr sein
wenn zu diesem zeitpunkt des unwetters
weder der vordere lupen deckel noch die
dahinter liegenden nachgaben wie kam das
meerwasser in den ruch
die frage war die wo im schiff konnte so
viel wasser eindringen dass der bug so
tief lag das wellen auf dem vorder deck
brachen
wochenlange versuche bleiben ergebnislos
bis das team eine theorie aufstellt die
fast zu unwahrscheinlich wirkt um sie zu
testen
belüftungsöffnungen auf den vordertüren
zu lagerräumen unter deck aufnahmen des
rocks zeigen dass die abdeckungen die
wasser aus der luft kanälen fernhalten
von der schweren see beschädigt wurden
konnte durch sie so viel mehr wasser
eindringen dass der bub geflutet wurde
man wusste dass der vorderste raum
geflutet worden da aber viele glaubten
nicht dass das etwas an der belastung
für die lütten deckel änderte
unklar war wie schnell das wasser
eindrang wir dachten testen und messen
wir es einfach
wir über trugen diese öffnungen auf das
modellschiff aber die frage war sind sie
groß genug können wir nachweisen dass
das schiff lange genug dem unwetter
ausgesetzt warum es komplett verlaufen
zu lassen
die lüftungsöffnungen sind so klein dass
gemessen an der größe des schiffs nur
ein rinnsal durch sie eindringen kann
aber teil von orchid wütete über zwei
tage lang genug um das rinnsal zur flut
werden zu lassen
wir konnten zeigen dass das wasser
schnell genug eindrang um die gesamte
vor peek verlaufen zu lassen
die geflutete buch sinkt tiefer in die
heranrollenden wellen immer mehr wasser
drückt auf die großen ladeluke deckel
[Musik]
innerhalb von fünf bis sechs stunden
überstiegen die wellen das zulässige
belastungs gewicht der logen decke alle
waren verblüfft dass so kleine öffnungen
diese kette von ereignissen in gang
setzen konnten das war der durchbruch
damit sind die ermittler endlich auf der
richtigen spur nun wissen sie wie es vor
zwei jahrzehnten zur katastrophe kommen
konnte
am zweiten tag im taifun nimmt das
schicksal der deutsche seinen lauf
20 grad steuerbar 20 grad steuerbord
captain immer sagte sie ahnen nichts von
der aufkommenden gefahr unter den vor
die lüftungs abdeckungen sind wechsel
das wasser in den lagerraum darunter
laufen kann von der brücke aus sieht man
das nicht es ist allgemein schwer zu
sehen vielleicht hätte man es anfang
eines vor mastes bemerken können aber
man kann nicht sehen ob es langsamer
aufsteigt oder ab sind
zwei tage lang trotz dieser bücher der
schweren see
jetzt schlagen die wellen über den bug
sie reichen bis zur locke zum ersten
laderaum
[Musik]
sie wird täglich
einer nach dem anderen geben die neuen
riesigen ladeluke deckel nach
wir werden sicher
man würde seinen augen kaum trauen und
während man es zu begreifen versucht
sinkt das schiff schon
nummer 2 liefern
von german nummer drei
nummer 4 56
dann nummer sieben acht neun direkt
nacheinander
dann ist alles zu spät
[Musik]
das schicksal aller an bord ist
besiegelt
das schiff sank so schnell dass sie
nicht mal einen notruf absetzen konnten
laut ermittlungen dauerte es nur wenige
minuten
[Musik]
am 8 november 2000 wird in london vor
gericht festgestellt dass die da vischer
sank nachdem wellen lüftungskanäle im
bug zerstört und ihn unter wasser
gesetzt hatten sie muss nun über ein
jahr lang damit leben dass der gutachter
der crew die schuld am untergang gab
heute wurde sie vollständig entlastet
außerdem drängt das gericht auf neue
sicherheitsstandards für
massengutfrachter darunter deutlich
stabilere lade luton deckel und
vorrichtungen um eine flutung des
vorderen bugs zu kontrollieren
die fast doppelt so stabilen lupen
deckel wurden international angenommen
und so sind massengutfrachter auf der
ganzen welt sehr viel sicherer geworden
dank der davis
2004 werden paul lambert und die dabeler
family association für ihren kampf um
sichere massengutfrachter mit dem thomas
grace silva orden der marien society
ausgezeichnet
es ist bemerkenswert mit wie viel
durchhaltevermögen sie die
untersuchungen vorangetrieben haben
ich glaube die dabeler wollte die
seeleute beschützen
aber irgendwann war es zu viel und sie
war müde
sie verlor den schwung im bug war
ständig unter wasser
und es war nur eine frage der zeit bis
eine welle die entscheidende lücke
eindrückte
da konnte sie dann nicht mehr
[Musik]